c'est une plaie blanc à port-au-prince
nous sommes venus pour l'ouverture du
navire hôpital du sns de la marine
américaine qui vient traiter les
haïtiens regardait la foule les gens qui
sont arrivés depuis deux jours qui
espère voir un médecin des milliers de
personnes des gens qui sont arrivés donc
lundi on a rencontré enfile des gens qui
venaient avec leurs enfants parce que
leurs enfants probablement une grippe
un enfant qui avait le nez qui coulait
on a aussi vu des cas beaucoup plus
lourd donc un oeil complètement tuméfié
une femme qui a amené sa jeune fille de
14 ans qui avait une tumeur à l'âge où
les d'aller voir un médecin plus tôt
cette année
en haïti ils ont retiré une partie de la
tumeur mais maintenant pour avoir
d'autres soins c'est pratiquement
impossible ça coûte très cher et donc
les gens viennent voir les médecins
américains car ce sont des services qui
sont offerts gratuitement et que
lorsqu'on parle aux gens on comprend
l'ampleur de la crise et de la pauvreté
en haïti la plupart des jeunes gens dit
qu'il venait ici pour voir les médecins
américains quand ce sont des services
qui sont offerts gratuitement
normalement il pourrait aller à
l'hôpital mais ils s'en sont incapables
n'ont pas les moyens de se payer une
consultation n'ont pas les moyens
d'aller voir les médecins haïtiens
et lorsqu'on parle aux gens de l'autre
côté de la rue qui regardent avec
curiosité cet être humain depuis deux
jours
et lorsqu'on leur parle de politique et
qu'on leur demande si la situation est
pire depuis l'opération payback
l'opération pays bloquées en haïti
donc depuis huit semaines les gens nous
disent que ça doit se terminer que ça
commence à être difficile pour à peu
près tout le monde à qui est la faute en
ce moment est-ce que c'est au président
joël moïse qui refusent de partir parce
que c'est ou aux manifestants qui
s'adonnent à la violence
en ce moment on nous dit que le système
doit changer qu'il doit y avoir un
compromis
c'était philippe leblanc à port au
prince